so let's talk Stevie Wonder cuz I know
y'all her friends do y'all like
literally hang out all the time and like
Stevie is probably I'm gonna tell you
something I I've been spending my whole
life with him thinking he can see I know
he could see no he can see listen the
story I tell this the funniest I went to
his house he says I want to hear a new
song I've got it in the car come on go
with me we go out to the car he says you
sit on the passenger side I'll sit on
the driver's side he goes in he cranks
the car up he puts the tape in right and
then he does this and it starts driving
back down the driveway no sir and I
scream said Stevie what are you doing
and he said got you didn't need to get
around him because every time I would
get around and I would not want to give
a phrase to him because he would write a
song with it if I say how are you doing
Steve how would you do
I'll see you later see you later I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this